[Music]
everyone loves toys and there are some
cool ones coming out this year
here to reveal some of the hot ones is
kathleen tomez
with brilliant marketing hey kathleen
how are you
i'm fantastic how are you super excited
to be here today i'm super excited that
you got the hot toys of the year what's
the first toy you're going to show us
all right first hot toy of the year is
by a company called habba and if you
want to be a hot parent or a hot
grandparent
get your kid the ahava dress me and
basically what it does
is it teaches your kids how to use like
fine motor skills and they basically can
pick from different outfits
like this and then they have to thread
it through
using their hands thinking through
process
hours of entertainment for your kids age
three and up
habba usa and you also get some hand-eye
coordination too kind of tie in the the
outfits together everything i love it
yes i mean everything's about the
hand-eye coordination these days
if you want to take it up a notch though
like in the entertainment so for kids
ages
4 up by power your fun it's the
intellisource so it's a dinosaur
that's remote control robot toy and
this dinosaur can walk it can dance it
can talk
it can bop its head so it's the
interactive play
plus some it even has some super cool
led lights so that's intellisore
that thing looks i want one of those
things from my house i've got two dogs
and i want a dinosaur to join the dogs
it does all the same
things yeah i mean make the dogs jealous
it's perfect
that's awesome all right so next up most
parents are familiar with the beautiful
books and writings and illustrations of
eric hall
well eric carl one of his most popular
books is a very hungry caterpillar
well a company called creaton created
magna tiles that basically illustrates
one of the world's most popular kids
books and what it does it's all these
magnets that you can put together
and it allows your kids to be able to
come up with different play patterns by
assembling the different tiles
you can create the journey that the
caterpillar goes on for the picnic or
his journey to creating a cocoon all by
creedon and this cute little
handy box i love i love that one it's
interactive too you're assembling stuff
you're assembling a book right there
that's really cool
you are i mean you're basically the
author you're assembling it yourself
that's right
all right so the world of building
blocks everybody knows about lego
well there's a a huge company
a hot on his trail it's called plus plus
and what it does is it takes little um
plus
size figurines i'm gonna show you guys a
couple and you put them together
and it's only one size so it's these two
little pluses if you guys can see them
and then they fit together to make all
different kinds of contraptions and the
one we're talking about today
is their windmill and it comes with the
box
you can put all the little plus plus
figures in and then the little platform
to then create the windmill
it's amazing but plus plus has hundreds
of different figures and sets that you
can create
all from one snake figure i mean talk
about teaching your kids how to get
creative well look something that's very
zen like too you can create and put on
your office desk it looks like a zen
toy uh i think for one more toy what do
you have for us
all right so uh the last one up is by
schleich it's the bayala
unicorn um and it schleich is
loved and adored by all it's it's
designed um animal figures
they're lifelike in their way that they
look they're obviously hand-held
this one is the unicorn that we love
that's super popular
it creates imaginative play your kids
can go up to land far far away
all wish like i love that my wife has
horses and she's texting me right now
she wants that one for
herself as well thank you so much
kathleen we appreciate it we'll have
more information
on these toys on our website mercedes
over to you